but we can already confidently say that such a
policy of relations with Russia failed; the
strategy of the economic blitzkrieg failed;
moreover, the sanctions were not in
vain, and for the initiators themselves,
I mean the growth of inflation and
unemployment; the deterioration of economic
dynamics in the United States and European countries;
has already withstood
this unprecedented pressure the
situation is stabilizing the ruble exchange rate has
returned to the levels of the first half of
February and is determined by an objectively
strong balance of payments
in the first quarter the positive
balance of the current account of the balance of payments has
flown in 58 billion dollars and this is a
historical maximum I will
separately dwell on the topic of inflation
now it is stabilizing but together  At the
same time, we are well aware that only over the
past month and a half, consumer
prices in Russia have increased markedly by 9.4
percent in annual terms.
As of April 8, ventilation
amounted to 17.5 percent.
I draw the attention of my colleagues from the government
and the central bank
we know about this very well all these are
very high values ​​people
feel it on their family budget
feel how you differ and we need to
support our citizens to help them
cope with the inflationary wave as
far as the budget is concerned I know the discussions
that are going on  between the central bank and
the governments, however, given the
objective nature of lending, of course, the
budget should actively hold back the
economy, saturate and
maintain the economy with financial resources, or
liquidity, there are, of
course, already opportunities for this to act carefully, the
minister and I talk about this constantly, but
nevertheless, following the results of the first  quarter of
this year, a record
level of officials of this budget system was recorded, here
additional decisions are needed and
they need to be implemented exactly at the
moment when it is most necessary to
save